اذا مشاهدينا روايتان حول سبب هذا التصميم
العمد لتلميذات المدارس في ايران روايه
الاولى هي لناشطين ومحتاجين ايرانيين ممن
اعتبروا ان الغايه وراء هذه الظاهره
الغريبه والغاز المسمم شكل من اشكال
العقاب على العصيان المدني والاحتجاجات
التي اظهرت عبر الجامعات والمدارس خلال
التظاهرات الماضيه والتي حملت شعار المراه
حياه حريه عقب مقتل الشابه ماسه اميني
منتصف سبتمبر الماضي اما الروايه الثانيه
فهي وفقا لمسؤولين من داخل النظام نفسه
فهم يتهمون حركه معينه تريد حظر تعليم
الفتيات في البلاد على غرار طالبان في
افغانستان اما عن الطريقه التي يتم بها
نشر هذا السم فيقول نشطون ايرانيون انها
تتم عبر استخدام اشخاص مجهولين للرذاذ او
ادوات لرش هذا الغاز السام الخفيف عبر
تجنيد فتيات باستطاعتهم الدخول
المدارس الفتيات او رش الغاز من خارج سياج
المدرسه نحو ساحه المدرسه وبالتالي تتعرض
الفتيات لاستنشاق الغاز وبالتالي الشعور
بالاعياء والغثيان طبعا هذا وفقا لروايات
ايرانيه اما عن نوع الغاز المستخدم في
عمليات التصميم هذه فوفقا لما اظهرته
نتائج فحوصات السموم التي توصلت اليها
وزاره الصحه ان الماده السامه المستخدمه
في قم تتكون بشكل خاص من غاز النيتروجين
ان اثنين المصنوع بشكل اساسي من
النيتروجين والمستخدم في الصناعه او كسماد
زراعيه
[موسيقى]